is there some kind of um
perfect number of minutes would you say
so we're talking about focusing on a
particular task
for you know one minute five minutes 10
minutes 30 minutes
is it possible to kind of context switch
while maintaining deep focus
you know every 20 minutes or so so if
you're thinking of like
this again maybe it's a selfish kind of
perspective but if you think about
programming
you know you're focused on a particular
design of a little bit maybe a small
scale on a particular function or a
large scale
on a on a system and then
the shift to focus happens like this
which is like
wait a minute is there a library that
can achieve this little task or
something like that
and then you have to look it up this is
the danger zone
you go to the internets yeah and and so
you have to
now you it is a kind of contact switch
because as opposed to thinking about the
particular problem
you now have switch thinking about like
uh consuming and integrating knowledge
that's out there that can plug into your
solution to a particular problem it
definitely feels like a contact switch
but is that is that a really bad thing
to do so should you be setting it aside
always
and really trying to as much as possible
go deep
and stay there for like a really long
period of time
well i mean i think if you're looking up
a library that's relevant to what you're
doing
that's probably okay and i don't know
that i would count that as a full
contact shift because
the semantic networks involved are
relatively similar
right you're thinking about this type of
solution you're thinking about coding
you're thinking about this type of
functions
where you're really going to get hit is
if you switch your context to something
that's
different and if there's unresolved
obligation so really the worst possible
thing you could do would be to look at
like an email inbox
because here's 20 emails i can't answer
most of these right now
they're completely different like the
context of these emails like okay
there's a grant funding issue or
something like this is very different
than the coding i'm doing
and i'm leaving it unresolved so it's
like someone needs something from me
and i'm going to try to pull my
attention back the second worst would be
something that's emotionally arousing
so if you're like let me just glance
over at twitter i'm sure it's nice and
calm and peaceful over there right
that could be devastating because you're
going to expose yourself to something
that's emotionally arousing
that's going to completely mess up the
cognitive platform there and then when
you come back to okay let me try to code
again
it's really difficult this is both the
information and the emotion
yeah both both can be killers if what
you're trying to do
so i would recommend at least an hour at
a time because it could take up to 20
minutes
to completely clear out the residue from
whatever it was you were thinking about
before
so if you're coding for 30 minutes you
might only be getting 10 or 15 minutes
of actual
sort of peak lex going on there right so
an hour at least you get a good 40 45
minutes plus i'm partial to 90 minutes
that's a really good
a really good chunk we can get a lot
done but just before you get exhausted
you can sort of
pull back a little bit
you